what I see when I hear the Trump attacks
and I hear desantis's silence is I see
two very skilled politicians because
right now Donald Trump has to attack Ron
DeSantis Donald Trump is out of the
government DeSantis is his chief rival
right now if he doesn't want to lose
momentum he's got to go on the offense
likewise Ron DeSantis who has a big
platform in Florida he can govern
because he is still in office he is very
smart to remain silent here and to just
keep doing what he's doing in Florida
and so I know there are a lot of
conservatives who want Trump to drop out
and endorse DeSantis or DeSantis not to
run and to throw his support behind
Trump I for one am very pro-primary I
love a good vigorous primary fight if a
conservative is going to beat Joe Biden
or whoever could replace him in 2024 we
need them to be toughened up and the
other great advantage of primaries is it
forces the candidates to move a little
bit more in the right word Direction